[Music]
right now we're in my orcas or getting
ready for the World Championships in
Apeldoorn I'm excited that we're going
in as a you know a big team and a lot of
power tech cycling is much more
different than other events on the road
and afraid it's much more specialized
science in sport is very very important
and we're proud to be involved with the
company and we know it makes major
difference the team goals for 2018 are
to of course
defend the world champion titles that we
got in 2017 and then as well have good
results with the men's team pursuit and
with our sprinters the world
championships are definitely important
they're stepping stones each year
leading into the Olympics as the
reigning world champions coming into
2018
there's a lot of emphasis on our team
pursuit and that's definitely we're
hoping to start off the year on a good
because of the physical demands and of
track cycling it's it's very very high
intensity and it came onboard with
science in sport range because we've
tried the now sales we've tested
themselves I've done 15 grand tours I've
done six Tour de France you know it was
always the product that I would turn to
because I knew it worked for me and I
had no problems with my stomach for 250
days in the Sun it was I knew I could
really trust the product doing multiple
events in a day for track cycling
between each race between each session
focusing on what you're putting into
your body what you're doing with your
body is really important
[Music]
you